okay welcome back to chess openings
explained as always my name is caleb
denby
and today i'm going to be taking you
through a very complicated variation in
the najdorf
it is a night of some small technical
issues here as
lee chess where all my analysis was
saved for tonight's class
mysteriously has gone down in the past
half hour
amongst other things so i am on
chess.com tonight
where we are sort of playing it by ear
going step by step
seeing how much of my analysis i
remember and good news is
it's a lot of it most of the analysis
tonight was focused more on the ideas
less around the concrete variations so i
was able to recreate
most of what i had planned to go over so
as i said it is the english
attack tonight which starts with one e4
c5
knight f3 d6 d4
takes takes knight f6
knight c3 a6 and then of course the move
bishop e3 by white denotes the english
attack and this is
a rather complex variation it's a very
popular choice for white
i think these days you will be facing
bishop e3 more often than bishop g5
which of course bishop g5 is sort of
seen as the toughest challenge to the
night or
but bishop e3 these days very very
popular move
now today the move i want to recommend
is the move e5
and for tonight's lecture we're going to
focus on the variations after the main
move
knight b3 knight f3 is also a move and
we will get to these variations
eventually
but tonight the focus is going to be on
this move knight
b3 now we do have the move bishop e7
by black and the english attack may the
main idea here
uh with this bishop on e3 the knight
coming back to b3
is in fact not the complicated f4
variations that we were looking at
in previous lectures but rather to go
with f3
and the idea being to expand with a
later g4 push
this is the break that white is really
hoping to play in the english attack
and then he'll continue on with g5 f4 to
follow
and start a monstrous attack on the
king's side
now with black you can start with the
move bishop e6 here
and if white gets too ambitious and
plays g4 right away
you do have the very nice move d5 to uh
to counter this idea so
white really cannot play g4 directly
because then d5 does become
a very good move the idea being that
after something like
g5 d4 will come on the board take on f6
take on f6 and white has no good way to
deal with the threat to
both pieces in fact black is going to be
better here
and if white tries to capture you have
the simple
knight takes d5 and here once again
there's bishop h4 check as well but you
can even just recapture
on d5 and black once again is going to
be better
with the centralized bishop and the
extra central space
thanks to the e5 pawn so g4 not playable
immediately
instead you do see the move queen d2
most often
now if black tries to do the same
business with d5 it's not quite as good
we see
uh takes on d5 and after something like
bishop takes d5
white is very ready to queen side castle
and this bishop isn't nearly as good
with this pawn back on g2
rather than g4 so all that being said
this is the reason why d5 isn't played
here
but also d5 is the reason why g4 isn't
played here uh
interesting to note so queen d2
is the main option here for white and
the reason is
it sort of uh gives white a little bit
of flexibility here
with what he wants to do white can now
after black's next move still queen side
castle
develop this bishop or even go for a
quick knight d5 all three of these
options
are going to be available to him uh and
so this is the main position
that i want to start from tonight queen
d2 we're gonna sort of
analyze to death all of the various
options after the move queen d2
uh and this sort of really is the main
position in the english attack
so back in the olden days players with
the black pieces would always castle
or play the move knight bd7 here but one
of the newer
inventions in the english attack has
come to realize
that this plan of g4 is rather annoying
and so it is very very topical these
days to play the move h5
with the sole purpose of stopping this
move g4
from white and i do think this is
black's simplest and black's best
uh best play against this idea of
playing g2 g4
so now like i said there are three main
options that i want to take a look at
tonight
there's the move knight d5 there's the
move bishop e2
and then there's the move queen side
castles
uh and so if white wants to play sort of
the classical way
of attacking on the king's side then
queenside castles is definitely going to
be the move
that your opponent chooses if they go
knight d5 or bishop e2
it's much more indicative of king side
castling
play and it's not going to be that wild
english attack
crazy checkmating race that you might be
expecting it's going to be a more
positional
approach and we'll definitely dive deep
into those but to start with
let's stay with the english attack
purists who would likely
queenside castle putting pressure here
and preparing
somehow to launch these pawns up the
board this is generally
the idea that players with the white
pieces sort of want from the english
attack
uh and while we're getting into it here
there's a couple questions
uh what is the range of feta elo i'm
attempting to teach well i'm hoping
even if you're a little bit lower rated
you can get exposed to some new
ideas in this nidorf variation that
perhaps
you weren't weren't quite familiar with
and then the the goal of the lecture is
to give you
a pretty complete understanding of this
variation in the night or
opening the point of this series is to
hopefully get you to the point
where even at a rather advanced level
you would be able to start playing the
night or
and understand a little bit about what
you're doing
uh so pretty wide range there i'm hoping
even lower rate of players can get
something out of it
but it is set to uh to be useful to a
higher rated audience as well
okay so queen side castles by white
and so now what does black do well
basically you can play very very
similarly
as to the main planes without h5
with the addition that h5 is just
included which means white's play is
going to come a bit more slowly
and so what does that mean well i would
rather not castle king's side
immediately because h5 does occasionally
serve to weaken the king's side for the
black king i think it makes a bit more
sense
to leave this king in the center for the
immediate future
without committing the king's side
castles and so the move knight bd7 is of
course the obvious choice
you just want to develop uh
your remaining pieces and play from here
now the main move by far is actually the
move king
b1 and this might not be what you would
expect from a position
like this generally
a lot of you know especially amateur
players that i talk to
in these positions if they are sort of
new to
these kinds of openings with queen side
castles and crazy attacks
it you get the feeling that you should
be playing as quickly as possible you
know like bam bam bam bam bam i want to
play g4 i want to play f4 i want to go
checkmate my opponent
but in many cases it's better to
keep your options a little bit more
flexible and king b1 is definitely
capable of doing that number one it
steps out of a
ton of potential tactics on the c file
later on
that white is almost certainly going to
have to deal with
and number two it's not yet showing
white's hand on the king's side
it's not revealing if white wants to go
h3 if white wants to go g3
if white wants to go f4 if white's
thinking of something else entirely
it's not yet showing black what he wants
to do
on the king's side and so black is going
to have to make
a decision for himself as well so king
b1
by far the most popular move and now
uh i like the move 11
b5 and this is sort of the
the start to black's ideas and from here
i want to look at quite a variety of
options that white can try and i want to
show you some ideas that black has
against all of them uh
with b5 of course black is signaling
that he wants to play
on the queen side in this variation
going after the white king
but there are some sort of deeper ideas
to it
as well number one we are
sort of securing the b6 square for the
knight
and as always in the night or if the d5
square is going to be a very very uh
important focus point or focal point for
both
the white side and the black side just
because we have these ideas
of a mating attack on the wings doesn't
mean the d5 square is sort of forgotten
about it's still going to be very
relevant here
in addition of course there are ideas of
playing b4
there are of course ideas of rook c8s
and attacking along the c
file but i do want to highlight that
it's not about forgetting
the d5 square entirely here blacks
many of black's main ideas still revolve
around
this square in making sure we keep this
square under control
now let's talk about some ideas for
white and we'll get into a little bit of
the specifics of how the game might
continue
so the move h3 is definitely a main
idea for white in these positions and
the point of h3 is sort of multi-fold
number one multi-fold i guess
so number one uh
let's switch after i i'll give you a q
um i've just gotten word that lee chess
is back and so i
we will be switching back to lee chess
eventually but uh
for all of the queenside castle's
variations i've got them all in
chess.com anyways so we're going to
stick with chess.com for now
anyways h3 the idea is hinting at
playing g4 anyways in many different
cases
it's also hinting at just controlling
the g4 square
and preparing a second break that white
very much could consider
and that break is going to be the move
f4 so h3
big idea white can also play g3 and this
very much is the slow way of getting to
play the move g4 anyways as we'll see h3
first
is not enough to achieve that and then
white can also
go in for knight d5 in many cases here
so why don't we start with this move
knight d5 because this is sort of
the most forcing variation
um so knight d5 and black
in these positions is almost always
going to take with
the bishop and this might not be your
first instinct as
very often it is good to preserve this
bishop and
take with the knight instead uh often
white is coming with g4 and g5 which
adds
or gains a tempo against this knight so
it makes sense to get rid of it but in
these positions i do like giving up the
bishop
and the reason is immediately thanks to
black's play we're able to challenge
this pawn
with both of our knights we wouldn't be
able to do this if we captured with the
knight
as the pawn would gain a tempo on the
bishop
and now because we are attacking this
pawn so thoroughly our pawn on b5 works
well to stop
ideas of white bringing a piece to the
c4 square
white really has no option here other
than t to uh to take on b6
to alleviate this pressure uh to the d5
pawn
and from here uh white has to try very
very hard
not to be worse in fact i think the only
way for white to not be worse is to go
in for a forcing variation with knight
a5
rook c8 and now knight c6
and this just leads to a rather equal
endgame that's
black should have no worries we can take
on d5 knight takes c7
knight takes c7 queen takes d6 rick
takes d6
or sorry and eventually rook takes d6
knight back to c6 and black is just
going to play king e7
it's an even material end game and black
is enjoying some extra central space
with uh non-zero prospects for the
knight
you know white is likely going to play
c3 to try to keep it out of these
squares
but c4 is a little bit weak sometimes
this knight can jump over here
and black definitely should not be worse
in this end game
if white would go for anything else in
these positions for example going back
to some idea like
h3 well black is sort of just taking
over
after a move like a5 or even b4 on the
queen side already
rook c8 is coming and black's play on
the queen's side
is just going to be coming through a
little bit faster
so that is the idea of a quick knight d5
in response to b5 now let's take a look
at
h3 a little bit earlier on i mentioned
that
h3 actually isn't with the idea of g4
and i say that because while white would
still love to play
g4 h3 gives black a pretty unique
opportunity
to lock down this g pawn almost forever
and that opportunity is with the move h4
after h4 of course now g4
is
not as ideal and the reason for that is
the move h4
shifts the fight there's this idea of of
shifting the square
that we're challenging you know black
was immediately challenging the g4
square
with the pawn on h5 white gained control
of that square so now we shifted the
fight
to the g3 square where white is much
less prepared
to uh to handle our defense
and so after h takes g3 something like
rook g1
these positions do tend to be totally
fine
for black if white wants to try a bit
harder he can start with rook g1
and this is still an acceptable way to
play for example something like queen c7
and g4 h takes g rook takes
g3 king f8 is generally a useful move to
guard these
regardless g7 pawn note that castling is
less good
because now it does make a lot of sense
to have this rook on the open h file
and after something like bishop g5 there
are various
uh various options now for black you can
try
knight b6 you can try rook c8 you can do
something
with b4 or even something like knight h5
and meeting white on the king's side
plenty of options here
so all of that is to say the idea of h3
isn't necessarily to play g4
because after h4 g4 is no longer such a
great idea
for white so what is the point then well
quite often the point is to play this
move f4
this is sort of what white is going for
in this position in most cases now if
white
plays f4 immediately we can i believe
just bring this knight to b6
except we can't this is one of those
positions
where it would have been nice to have my
analysis in front of me so i don't say
silly things like knight p6 so that
would win
for white if knight b6 immediately so in
this case we do have to try a little bit
harder
of course in this position uh if white
plays f4 immediately
now we can challenge with b4
and white would have to contend with
losing this e4 pawn if this is what he
wants to play
now this isn't awful for white because
queen takes b4 can be played
but at the end of the day black is going
to be doing just fine
with the strong e4 pawn off the board
this knight can sink
into g3 another advantage of having this
pawn on h4
and at the end of the day white is now
fighting to open up the center
so we're quite happy to castle king's
side with this play sort of locked down
f takes e5 for example knight takes e5
and black is doing fine
in in this position now if white tries a
little bit harder
and defends the e4 pawn before
before going for f4 for example
something like bishop d3
now after the move queen c7 if we try f4
we can i think in this position play the
move knight b6
unless i'm crazy unless i'm crazy i do
think knight b6
makes a lot of sense uh in this position
and if something like queen f2 to
challenge the knight then knight a4
or knight c4 are both very reasonable
options
and the reason why i want to play knight
b6 is because it's a direct response to
the threat of playing f5
when now we're quite happy to drop this
bishop back to the d7 square
once again just supporting our plans of
playing on the queen side
this is why we bring the knight out to
b6
so this is the idea of h3 pretty much
and once again
you see ideas of playing b4 ideas of
bringing queen out to c7
for knight b6 and play on the queen side
in those positions
uh if white tries the sort of
stubborn beat your head against a wall
approach with g3
now this is sort of the signal that
white very much is still trying to play
g4 that's what g3 is about the point is
it stops this idea of playing h4
for black to prevent the move g4
and it's still going with h3
and g4 to follow of course the downside
to this is it is quite slow so black can
play the move queen c7
almost always a really good idea note
that queen c7 generally should be played
before the move knight b6
because then the move queen f2 is
awkward in
in some cases not always but in many
cases it is awkward so queen c7 is good
to include with the idea being there's
none of these nasty tactics
or anything of that nature uh
now let's say white goes h3
like i said sort of stubbornly going for
g4
now we can still just continue with
knight b6
rook g1 is also necessary to break the
pin on the h
file and now already we're coming
through with the move b4
and life is is reasonably awkward now
for
white if you step back to e2 knight c4
is sort of devastating and uh this is
just going to be
very very good for black so the point of
showing this line isn't necessarily that
your white opponents are going to be
going for this type of business because
it honestly isn't the best
for white black does very very well in
those positions but it's showing how
powerful the idea of
h5 is it sort of prevents this idea of
g4
entirely at least under the
circumstances that white would hope to
attain it it just takes far too many
moves
to get this g4 move through
so with all that in mind those are sort
of the main options and main ideas
that i've come up with for black in
these positions after queenside castles
so i'll open it up to any chat room
messages
regarding this queenside castles
variation
uh i didn't cover uh every exact line
and tale
because i've lost my uh you know exact
analysis
but hopefully you have a good
understanding of the ideas now
for black once again those ideas
involving queen c7 and knight b6
some ideas of jumping this knight to a4
and pressure on the c
file as well as ideas of b4 and the main
point of black's play
has been he's done a very good job of
preventing
white's immediate breakthroughs on the
king's side with stuff like g4
that's the power of the move h5 alright
any
questions for me any questions
all right well in that case i think we
are going to take a very brief pause
as i pull up leeches to get back to my
analysis because i've heard it's back
so allow me just a few moments here to
get that underway
okay maybe we won't come back to leeches
i don't know how i feel about this
um
okay back to chess.com back to chess.com
it is
all right it was a good effort
we really tried but still coming off the
cuff here
let's get back to business so of course
we just went over
the variations involving after queen d2
h5 these variations with white queen
side castling
now i did mention that there are two
other main options here the immediate
knight d5
is very popular as well as this move
bishop e2
and i do think after queenside castles
this sort of stubborn way of still
going for these uh attacks on opposite
sides
they do tend to be actually pretty
comfortable for black you know black
does have enough resources there
with these ideas of b5 queen c7 and
knight b6 to have a very good game
so these days i think actually the
better approach for white is with this
move bishop e2
and it's sort of the same idea as the
immediate knight d5 but just a little
bit improved with bishop e2
so we'll talk about why that is here uh
so if white goes knight d5 immediately
uh now
hold on if i can sort of remember
my analysis there's one of these
variations where
knight d5 is premature but now i think
here we do still play bishop takes d5
and the point now
is after e takes d5
uh black is able to prevent white's main
idea in this position and actually
okay i'm gonna do something ben don't
get mad at me i'm gonna reopen
this crazy lee chess board ah and it's
down
it's down never mind okay i just wanted
to double check my analysis really quick
because hold on my brain is is killing
me here
what do you do when you can't remember
your own analysis it's tough
all right tell you what let's start with
bishop e2 because i remember what's
going on after bishop b2
uh
okay all right i remember the difference
now so let's talk about bishop e2
first still so the reason bishop b2 is
better
than knight d5 is because it isn't yet
committing
to knight d5 and what this means is that
black is going to have to play another
move here
and oftentimes that move is going to be
knight bd7
it really doesn't matter if you castle
or play knight bd7 first
either way white is likely going to
castle castle
and now from here black has committed to
playing this move
knight b to d7 what does this mean
well this means after the move knight d5
bishop takes d5 e takes d5
and uh so sorry what does this mean this
means after the move knight a5
which you can play after this variation
and i have to play one more move again
ah such a mess
such a mess
okay things are falling apart i'm
forgetting the specific details
ah
okay
so let's go knight d5 here all right i
think this is this is finally it there's
so many different
tricky move orders that it would have
been really nice to have it all in front
of me for this lecture but
technically issues what can you do so
knight d5 first and now the point is
after bishop takes d5
e takes d5 and king's side castles white
now has the option
to play this move knight a5 what has
changed well by playing bishop e2
first now you have sort of baited black
into bringing this knight
to d7 why does that matter well now
black no longer has control of the c6
square and i think finally
i have arrived at the variation here
okay and so the point now for both sides
is that with this knight on a5 white is
creating some very uncomfortable
pressure here this knight on a5 yes
challenges this pawn on b7 but it also
prevents this pawn on b7 from moving
somewhere like b5 which would be
very beneficial because of this idea of
playing the move knight c6
so for in response to
this move black players have quite often
played the move queen c7
there's also a very good chesapeal
repertoire by
alex kolovich who recommends the move
queen c8s
with a subtle idea of dealing with this
knight on a5
the problem with queen c7 is white can
sort of leave this piece here forever
and it is always going to be a little
bit uncomfortable for black to deal with
so alex's idea was to come queen c8 to
clear the d8 square for the bishop
but my contribution to the body of
theory is actually to play the move
queen
b8s and the reason for this is
a little bit you know non-non-intuitive
uh basically the idea is that after
something like queen c8
king's side castles
ah okay i figured that out i figured it
out we take with the knight here in this
variation and play the move bishop f5 i
figured it out
this is why things didn't look right
okay so bishop f5 and then castles
castles and everything makes sense
though knight a5 and
here is where queen c8 or queen c7
have been the main moves and so the
point is after queen c8 with the idea of
bishop c8
white has a very subtle move c3
and the point now is that if black does
try to go bishop d8
suddenly this move knight c4 becomes an
issue
and the reason knight c4 is such a big
deal is we've removed all of our
defenders
from this d-pawn and would have to play
the move queen b8
here so the idea occurred to me why not
play queen b8 immediately
and i do think that this is actually a
perfectly fine way of playing now
for black so if you're against a really
well-prepared white opponent who
remembers this idea of playing c3 in
response
to the queen coming around for this idea
of bishop b8
well now c3 simply makes no sense the
move bishop d8 comes anyways
if knight c4 you can immediately break
with b5
and black is controlling all of the key
squares
on the queen side and gosh i can't
believe it took me so long to remember
this idea of bishop f5
but now everything makes sense i
remember everything
[Music]
uh okay
so uh the point now is after queen b8
white has two main ways of playing uh
basically white can be aggressive and
try to play for c5 immediately
and i do think that this is the only way
to really try to prove anything
with white here the point of this is
that
queen b8 looks a little bit silly when
met with the fact that white is playing
for a quick c5 you know if white plays
like this you would sort of much rather
have this queen on c8 to help contest
the c5 square so i do think that this is
the best way of playing
for white there uh there is however also
the option of sort of just taking your
time in these positions with white
bringing the rooks to the center and
we'll talk about that as well
for the moment though let's focus on
this move c4
so c4 and the idea now for white is to
play rook a to c1
and sort of immediately try to break
through on
the queen side now of course black's
whole idea with queen b8
is to play this move bishop d8 and
challenge this knight
on a5 now why is this bishop
so important here well many times you're
not actually going to capture this
knight on a5 directly
it's sort of here as a preventative
measure it sort of
locks down white's play on the queen
side now how does it do that
well the point is white would love to
play b4
and c5 this is white's main idea in many
of these positions
but now thanks to this bishop on d8 this
plan
becomes a lot less attractive in face of
the move bishop takes a5
and b takes a 5. now what black is happy
to bring this queen
back out to c7 and black is sort of
taking
control of all of the dark squares on
the queen side
and this is the main idea of this bishop
back on d8
as i just said uh so
white can try to play this move b4 but
after takes on a5
and takes on a5 i do think that black
actually has
a a very reasonable position here you
can start with the move
queen c7 you can actually also play a
move like queen d8
the idea being you occasionally want to
bring this queen out
to the king's side you can also even
play a move like rook
c8 going for immediate pressure on the c
file
bishop g6 is also always a very nice
improving move in these positions for
black
preparing to launch the f pawn in many
cases and also stepping out of any f4
ideas
which would pressure both the bishop and
this pawn on h5
so let's stick with queen c7 for example
queen c7
rook ac1 would make sense and now
immediately
i think i like the move knight c5 just
locking down
this c pawn and going about your day
if f4 we can take bring this bishop back
to g6
and black is ready to challenge the
center of the board by bringing rooks
uh over to the e file
okay with that in mind what if white
doesn't go for this move b4 what if he
just wants to leave this knight on a5
forever i do think that this is
a slightly more uh critical try
for white so let's say he plays the move
rook a
to c1 well there's no need to panic just
yet you can play the move bishop back to
g6
like i said always a good improving move
for black bringing the bishop back
preparing to launch this pawn in many
cases
and now depending on what white does
black has a variety of
options so the best try that i could
find is actually bringing this bishop
back
to d1 and this might not make the most
sense at first glance but the idea is
you want to bring this bishop out to a4
and challenge this knight here on the d7
square challenge its claim
to the c5 square so i like this move
bishop d1 by white
and then for black i found a pretty
interesting idea here
where you can actually capture on a5
queen takes a5 and immediately play the
move b5
and i think that black is doing totally
fine
in these variations with this queen
on a5 it's sort of difficult to ever
capture this pawn as after a takes b
this rook is very very active on the a
file and gains a tempo
against this guy right here so the move
queen d2
makes a lot of sense just stepping out
of these ideas
um and now after for example the move
rook c8s
with the move b5 black is diverting sort
of all of the play immediately to the
queen's side
uh so he can afford to draw this rook
away from the f file and over to the c
file
now bishop e2 makes sense to pressure
these pawns
and after something like b takes c4
bishop takes c4
queen or knight b6
bishop back to b3 for example and
uh i guess we should take on c1 first
black now expands with the move a5
and is looking to play a4 and like i
said the whole point of this
was basically that black is able to
divert all of the play
over to the queen's side and he's able
to open up these files
with b5 and i do think black is doing
well in
sort of all of these variations there's
ideas as well after a4
of playing something like queen b7
challenging this guy
there's also ideas of actually playing
f6 and bishop f7
to challenge this pawn as well and white
is not going to have an easy time
keeping everything defended in this
particular case actually i'm not even
sure knight b6 makes the most sense
immediately maybe we should start with
the move a5
with black here as well but like i said
ideas of knight b6
ideas of f6 and bishop f7
and ideas of just using these open files
on
the queen side for black in these
positions
good stuff uh so that's sort of the idea
uh if white tries to do something
like this bishop maneuver and if white
doesn't do anything
for example just play something like h3
there are a variety of options
here for black this idea of b5 makes
less sense when the bishop still
guards this square but you can also play
for an idea of pushing for e4 so for
example something like rookie 8
and if whites plays a slow move we can
play already
something like bishop h4 i guess in this
particular instance
but if you know a waiting move like king
h1
you can play something like h4 and the
idea is going to be e4 to follow
when the play is going to start to open
up a little bit also notably there are
some other ideas
for black on the queen side one of which
is taking on a5
and instead of going for this b5 idea
now that this bishop is still here to
guard
black can also sort of consolidate
things on the queen side
with something like b6 and a5 this is a
great
locking pawn structure that now makes it
very very difficult
for white to break through with these
natural ideas of b4
and with this of course black is also
getting control over the c5 square
and is still playing for this move e4
with ideas of knight d3 to follow
and once again i think it's just going
to be a comfortable game here
for black so a wide variety of ideas
for black to choose from in these
positions but i just wanted to highlight
a few of those
if white tries this sort of fast idea of
rook to c1
okay backing up a bit if white tries to
play a bit more slowly let's say
c4 bishop d8 and he just brings all of
his pieces to the center
like this well now black in fact has
even more options
including this move f5 including some
ideas of playing bishop b6
giving up this idea of attacking this
knight in return
for the bishop trade and those lines
might go something like
takes takes let's say
not queen c2 but b4 instead knight back
to d7
and with these bishops off the board
black is
once again going to be playing for some
free maneuvers like b6
and a5 okay
so any questions on this idea of the
early
knight a5 any ideas of this knight a5 or
questions on this knight a5 stuff
uh matisse says c b a b queen c7 looks
terrible for black i'm not sure
if i can recreate the position you're
talking about you likely meant
after let's see bishop g6 bishop d1
is this where we're at bishop a5 b5
cb ab queen c7 looks terrible
for black i am not sure i agree
uh there are a lot of good things for
black here in fact i do think black
might just immediately be winning a pawn
with the move knight f6
two things are under attack at the same
time you can play bishop b3 to defend
but now this bishop can actually reroute
over to c4
this queen has to fix itself
and then for example if you take on c4
all of these guys hang
and d5 is still going to be weak
good question though good question
any other questions all right
well let's move on so what if white
doesn't immediately play this idea
of knight a5 what if he just goes c4
instead
and says hey i am going to play the move
c5
and destroy you in the center well now
if white doesn't play the move knight a5
black can actually prevent it forever
with the move a5 himself now the
immediate c5 actually isn't going to be
good
for white because a4 is coming with
tempo if you take on d6
i'll take back knight c1 and this d pawn
is going to be a much bigger weakness
than it is an asset here for white ideas
of e4 ideas of knight f6 and this pawn
is just going to be a bit too weak
for white to be comfortable
so if white can't play c5 and tries to
prepare it
well now after b6 we once again have
this good
pawn structure to lock down things on
the queen side in this case we also
haven't had to give up our dark squared
bishop for this knight
so it should be an even better version
here for black
now once again play is going to shift to
the king's side once we lock things down
white can try something like f4 but
black is hoping to play bishop g6
f5 e4 himself and
come out with his pieces to the king's
side of the board while still
allowing this knight to come out to the
c5 square
okay so then let's talk about
knight d5 immediately now that i finally
have my bearings we can take with the
knight
play bishop f5 and now from here
if something like bishop e2 once again
this idea of a5 is why this move order
is sort of less desirable
for white than the previous move order
you just don't have time
to bring this knight out to a5 and if
you
do try to bring the knight out to a5 now
since this knight is still on b8 black
actually even has an extra option here
to immediately kick this knight out with
the move
b6 of course now this knight unable
to come in to the c6 square thanks to
our knight still being back on b8
for example knight c4 knight d7 and
black once again
is going to play this locking move a5
and
we'll have very similar to play to what
we just saw
um okay
so with all that in minds
uh i think that's most of what i had to
go over tonight it was a rocky road and
probably i would have a little bit more
to talk about if i had my full analysis
in front of me
but i think maybe we should call it a
day
here i've had a blast talking to you
guys
through this uh these main variations in
the bishop e3 neidorf sorry it was a
little bit bumpy tonight
but sometimes they just don't that you
know the world just
isn't ready for you to teach a chess
class uh hopefully
you got some useful ideas out of the
lecture tonight
i am going to continue to talk about the
bishop e3 night or
next week perhaps i'll go over some
lines that i
missed in this week because i didn't
have the analysis in front of me i'll
also be going over
some different stuff like the early
knight f3 that i mentioned
was a choice for white as well as other
sidelines in this bishop e3
english attack uh with all of that in
mind
thank you guys so much for joining me
here live stay tuned because we are
about to go live on twitch
with the tactics time uh tactics time
class
where i believe with the chats help we
are going to be pushing uh onwards to
the 2700 land on leeches
tactics well are we hmm
all right we'll see we'll go live on
twitch with something something
related to tactics anyways thank you
guys so much for joining me here tonight
and bearing with me through some of
those issues uh i will see you guys next
time as always my name is caleb denby
uh thanks for watching
[Music]
you